hi everyone I'm David Griffin now
Michael Medina bring you this week's
review of arrow season 2 episode 14 time
of death now this week's episode was
interesting i think this episode maybe
took a step back in terms of quality it
wasn't bad but i was watched it was like
okay like I think all the meat happened
at the very end and usually arrow give
us a lot of stuff in between but this is
a very family centric episode it was a
relationship episode it was a love
triangle episode what you think about
this mom gets he Diggle do a little
something he got he got a little bit
more no you know I initially I agree
with you in the beginning I thought I
was like I was just gonna kind of be
like a villain of the week type of thing
I had that vibe but I actually liked it
a little bit more I mean I actually kind
of liked it was a little family-centric
yeah I like that we got the drama
between laurel and her family so cuz we
knew it was eventually gonna happen at
some point we see like her dad trying to
reconcile with his wife at dinner and
then Laurel and Sara chicken chicken
cacciatore does not work no but now I
definitely like the the whole family
element to it and then we should get to
see a little bit of like Oliver and his
mom yeah and you know to see a little
bit more although I with the whole like
her being mayor running from me I would
have liked to have seen that angle play
out a little bit more because that's
that's gonna be big it's gonna play a
huge role he figured because we know
that destro you know Slade went over to
talk to her about because he knows that
she's in the race and she's challenging
you know again who else didn't see his
brother blood you know we didn't see him
a lot of is a good week it's just a lot
who left out I thought we I was hoping I
know you were hoping to you told me that
you would want to see more Roy yeah I
see really i mean Roy showed up at the
party but we did get seriously on the
scene yeah I totally agree because I
mean that last episode when they
introduced when he gets introduced to
the group and so it was an exciting
episode I really liked that episode so I
was like all right I figured maybe the
following week we'd get that yeah we
didn't that's fine but then I'm like are
at some point we got to start singing
train sorry cuz that's that's exciting
but unfortunately can get that I
remember I know a lot of us have you
know you know think hero fans mifi both
been complaining about Laurel not doing
much perhaps this episode was meant for
Laurel to get over the home kind of wrap
that whole yeah well she had the nice
touch him at the end with her sister
and you know so maybe now and she goes
to a meeting with her dad so maybe now
you know I don't know finally me over
the last this yeah there's something to
do right be nice a little bit just a
little bit dull with her I think yeah um
you know as always some great every week
so I some good easter eggs yeah the
Coriolis guy right here maybe the
lecture enterprises for the prizes yeah
plus it's like a little
blink-and-you'll-miss-it moment on the
bus when all of it goes to stop that bus
you see a poster for a blue devil right
on the side was just kind of cool and
stuff so I love when they do stuff like
this you don't want to stop a bus from a
moving train or just go in front of the
bus is your motorcycle just kind of put
your hand up you guys gonna stop not
gonna stop it's all that happens that's
how it works but no III I enjoyed this
episode again I would have liked to seen
a little bit more Roy I like that
they're starting to kind of wrap up the
whole like Laurel thing um Deathstroke
really was kind of blew my mind I was
not expecting you know it's just
happened more at the end exactly exactly
exactly he's like I'm in the middle of
the meeting right now I did not see that
coming that was cool you know let's talk
about Felicity a little bit i mean you
know they had the whole olicity got a CW
originals Vampire Diaries star cross
gotta have a little rain CW is going to
have love triangles if you watch CW show
you can not escape but maybe supernature
doesn't have that as much but anyway I
like seeing a Felicity get her battle
scar she earned your stripes it was nice
absolutely and obviously you know
whether or not Oliver and Felicity
actually end up together who knows but
obviously can't work out all perfectly
there's gotta be a few bumps right you
know but um uh oh I'm just kind of been
a little bit of an ass I'm he knows how
Felicity feels about his own and show
some class no I overall though I really
enjoyed this up so I thought the I
thought it was good writing for this
episode I like the action I thought the
pacing worked well and stuff yeah I was
a little heavier on the family but I
don't I kind of like that change of pace
lot diggle's keyboarding skills were
excellent it just comes act like it's
not working is nothing weird we know
that Diggle I guess we talked about some
future thing now is that we saw the
Suicide Squad pictures we saw a Diggle
there so Diggle is gonna get to do some
play a bigger role not now he's not
doing much no more of this like you know
his quota like I get to do one thing per
episode I'm gone I'm gonna hit the
computer button over and over again to
see although i will say speaking of
Diggle I did like that scene early
in the episode when they're training
with the staffs and stuff implant
comparing like battle scars is kind of
fun it's like oh I'm so sorry I cut you
think I'm so sorry so let's stop we got
a little bit a little origin story this
week yes the origin of sin mm-hmm we see
now what happened with Sarah and finding
that this pilot who who was shot out of
the sky and had a daughter that he was
worried like please take care of her so
it looks like now we know we're sins
origin story a little bit anyway yeah
absolutely and she's kind of underused
right now I'd like to see her a little
bit more too but I understand a show
like this you know with so many
characters it's kind of hard to throw
everything at you and once then you
don't want to do that either and stuff
so hopefully we can you know kind of
flesh her out a little bit more there's
also looking at the the lack of some
characters that we haven't seen a lot we
haven't seen summer glau for been ages a
long time it's always like long break
since I haven't seen in a year yeah
Malcolm Merlyn ya got the little cool
cool it's a great see you great scene I
mean I mean you know you know Moira kind
of scared them off for a little while
but for how long exactly so we're still
waiting on some characters to come back
there's still some new which character
to introduce some of you do come I've
noticed on the comments your gripes
about the show that sometimes the show
does too much absolutely it introduces
too many characters it bounces around
too much doesn't stay focused on a
certain story I agree with you I think
they can get away with it a little bit
more though because of its a 20-over so
its season so they can do that more if
it was like 10 or 30 episodes like Game
of Thrones it be to clear something like
that yeah but they have a lot of time to
work so I think it's all going to wrap
up in the end but you feel it when
characters run around Absalom summer
glau just mistaken you know mysteriously
just disappears for like two months like
yeah where is she she runs a company
with Oliver worse and that's tricky do I
think they do a better job at that then
maybe some other shows but after a while
it does get kind of tough to juggle all
these characters and stuff which is you
know it's a good and bad thing obviously
if you're like a comic book fan you love
like just opening up the universe and
seeing everyone but I mean it does make
sense to kind of like you know slow but
steady right so this week you know
another good episode another solid
episode again I thought was it may be a
little bit of a step back not bad it's
not a bad episode just you know a lot of
family drama a lot of awkward dinner
table situations a lot of love triangles
you know just maybe too much of that but
anyway another great episode next week
you know hopefully the show will come
back there's no more breaks no we're
back
I'm gonna break any more breaks dad
can't do them but as always we come chat
with us and find us you know all the
information you want to know about a
think hero at think hero calm we also
have a Twitter page with a come chat
with dennis michael myself talk about
everything arrow and CW and love
triangles that you wanted to or at think
hero i'm at griffin de nom at mr.
Michael Alexis oh we also have a YouTube
page and check out this youtube page
right here all of our videos doing
walking dead game of thrones is coming
up soon done send away detective every
week check out our reviews think hero
pro and finally you know we have a
Facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think hero fans give us a like thumbs up
subscribe to this page spread the word
but everything think hero and glorious
and TV and phone right now and we'll see
you see you soon
you